これじゃ時た
初めてお久しぶりです地球の皆さん
欧風ロッテ入りますかまあ一般的にお風呂に入る際には皆様よく入浴剤というものが
使われていますがもしその入浴剤が固まったらすごくないですか
といて今回はこちら
する変わる入浴剤というものを見つけました話ですね3つの変化が楽しめる入浴剤と
なっております説明しましょう
まずフラスコに水かお湯を入れますとすごいですよねフラスコがついてるかな
パッと見も実験ですねそのエーザイをすべてこの中に入れて振って混ぜるとなんとこの
入浴剤
答えになりますこれ普通だとありえない現象です
さらにそんな彼に b を入れて混ぜるとやっと液体になるというすごくないか入浴剤
なのに答えになったり嫌いになったり色が変わるかつ
固体と液体の変から楽しめるわけでございます
うわぁ凄い滅いろんなバリエーションがありますね一見ちょっと普通に作ってみ
ましょうか
上下早速3種類や手間作っていこうまずはお前
一時の香りうわぁでちょっと端っこが付いている
まず水を入れますただの水 h 2 o でこの女ずにまずエーザイを入れますまあ
普通は思っ
で粉末状が解けた色のついた行きたいなるはずなんですけどもう
しっかり見てくださいね
あれ山へ
う
傘はチャッそうなんですこれ
水が答えになる[ __ ]でおねえ入浴剤なんです
他のもやってみましょう次はラベンダーの通り水を入れてエーザイ部首本で行く風
これもまた最初は水なんですけど混ぜていくと
あら不思議
交代になるんです森の通りもやってみましょういきます
失火に混ぜるとあるし
湖西ですというわけで答えになってしまったがこれでは入力さんの役はでができないと
いうわけで b 剤を入れていきます
今はまだ答えとくなが混じっている状態ですがこれをこうやってやっていきます
見ててくれ何がからブラッ
ん
このこれあれそうです何と液体に戻りますそれも色もカーレンでオレンジ色っぽくなり
ましたね
素晴らしい他の犬をやってみましょう
なんとこちらも紫の期待に変わります
ちょっと最後
きたきたきたどういう格変化するのはなすごいよねー
0期待になりました
凄くないかいきたいと答え合わせるとこんなにカラフルになります
美しいで普通にこれはもう入浴剤として来い使うことができます
廃校するとまぁいつも通りお風呂が入れるというわけでございます
はいというリクがだっただろうか入浴剤だがあの new 具材の a の粉は水を
答えにしますということだ
me
私は気づいてしまった
+校の中からの水辺あれば答えにできるわけですよねそんなに
結果図2図カール入浴剤があれば僕は1ちゃーん
お風呂の水丸ごと素材にできるのではないかと思いまして今日の需給は大量のフルフル
カールのエーザイよっ
ブーブー言ってる子
大量の英断で打ち込んでウーどぅっにょこれを全部開封して中のエーザイで取り返そう
と思ったんですけどさせ屋に
ん
時間がたっ
強いけどなんと今回特別に何か凝縮された特別な
エーザイの塊を準備させてもらいました
多分だから広範囲を入れてこのニュー具材いいらしいよする宇津根で
混ぜればすること固まります
ブーバー妹ちゃん単純へ here やっぱお前を殺すまあマーっ
かさ今日はめちゃくちゃなんか超高級な入浴剤が見つかったのでちょっとめちゃくちゃ
入れてもう値段なら寒い中2000万円くらいいいようですよいろいろそれくらいの
ニュータイプ使うのに君がない中 ae かわいいよ other あっあっ
着替えて入りましょうはいそうねっ
範囲という人市立明さんいらっしゃいませんようこそもう
ある調べてくださいねはい
まずはこちらを入れていきましょう
行かせはーい
[音楽]
いい階ですね2時こちらいきましょう
すって動いよ乙欄ああ
最高部に行くんですよいますねー
入った
パブーおっおっえっなにこれなにこれ
ランドネこれすごい
ですねはい覚えか
nao いやー
r 3経済は終わってないですかねぇ
yeah
針というわけで
オギャー
固まってしまうドッキリでしたアーチャー
いや本当に動かないヤバイ感じで大変
やばい本当にフーッあっはーん
ran
まず山理バスじゃないですこれ
ふーんぐらい覚えて apparel ガチガチ
本当にやばいわー
まーまーきみあー政治がないちゃんと入浴剤になるんです
びっくりし
お空の b 剤を入れるとなんと答えがちゃんと行きたいになってきれいな入浴剤に
変わります
ようやった
入れますねはいおやつは受けると思う
[音楽]
ホラって来ればすぐ溶けてるだけじゃなかったんじゃない
キターすごいぱポケット付たでしょ
行列は復活しましたうっ拡張した完全にすごいですこれが b 剤の力です
大丈夫剤とだけで私ドクターつ目
youtube の番台に公式チャンネルに持っている
おりますので是非皆さん見てみてくださいね
もう1回 a 材料かハオハオ4 a
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ